one line Vince wrote hiding in plain
sight and that line was an inspiration
to me and that led me to to really think
about oh Gus is hiding in plain sight
he's a model citizen I did another guest
spot and they offered me a contract and
I said let's wait and they called next
season and repeated their offer and I
said I'd love to speak to the Creator
because I wanted to do something
different I was convinced I didn't want
to see the stereotypical bad guy I
didn't want to see the mafiosa I wanted
to be a guy who was affable part of the
community who handled his business like
a business it was the calm demeanor that
I bought to this character that I feel
like allowed him to be elevated yoga
breathing it was my attention on someone
else brutal to them if they don't do
what he says but he's very kind to them
if they do he is the ultimate father in
the laundry business in the drug
business and in the chicken business so
I asked to speak to Vince Gilligan we
had a long conversation uh and we were
on the same page and and things took off
after that